so you've been at 30 rock forever now i
feel like yeah no matter the job so so
do you do you get along with everybody
in the building or is there like one guy
that's like ugh every time you walk in
no i i've been there for 25 years now
isn't that crazy
wow
at nbc going in the same elevators it's
bizarre yeah i know everyone there at
one point i used to have like keys to
different offices and stuff because dan
aykroyd came to the show uh and was so
nice to me and he was like so you're the
new kid i go yeah he goes uh hey jimmy
come with me i want to show you the spot
he goes i used to hang out with all the
security guards he goes me and belushi
would come down to this this area and we
crawled we broke into an office this is
serious crawled through a window
and we went out in the out there was
this giant beautiful lawn like a patio
that's just like on the 11th floor and
we went out and it's just a gorgeous
place it was like an old like back in
the day they used to have tuscanini's
his office but him and belushi and akra
would go and just get high up there yeah
thank you for saying that i wasn't gonna
say i'm trying to think of how to say
that yeah yeah i have a second okay we
gotta read books
and just make sure everything is good
yeah we call it so we
were friends with all the security guys
so like uh yeah so we would go around
and just break into stuff and just he's
like oh you're the new guy let me show
you the break and enter yeah
yeah
yeah but then you know years later you
know being friends with acroid i would
say one of my biggest most fun nights we
ever had was the uh 40th anniversary of
the show and yeah at the end at the
after party we just had an empty stage
with instruments all set up no band
booked no one's booked and one at a time
everyone just grabbed guitars drums
started their own band and everyone got
on stage and aykroyd started this party
and he called me up and it was him it
was jim belushi and paul mccartney and
they're like uh where's jimmy fallon
where's jimmy what i got up and he
tapped me he goes all right kid this is
your turn now he gave me the mic and i
ran it like a human karaoke box like you
and i i was like anyone who was in town
i saw taylor i go tell her do you want
to get up and sing so he's like yep
taylor got up saying something ariana
got up and sang something oh my gosh
blondie b-52s this was the end of this
part this is the party that everyone was
at
get ready for the end
so it's everybody good thing open with
paul mccartney close with what are you
close with a wild guess oh wait no i've
heard prince prince yeah okay so prince
is the guy with this party
so i we're on stage and chris rock says
to me hey prince is here by the way if
you probably asked nicely he might come
up and do something i don't know and i
was like i just grabbed him like prince
are you here
and then the crowd parted it was like a
purple
cloud of smoke and i swear his feet
weren't touching the ground his legs
were just kind of floating like and he
kind of floated he kind of floated up
and he floated up towards me and i go
wow i got to embrace the moment it's
happening you know
this might be death this is what death
is i don't know maybe it's life i don't
know he came up he pulled off these long
gloves i took them i handed him a guitar
and he's saying let's go crazy at like
four in the morning in new york city can
i tell you
can i tell you my favorite part of that
story is he took office
that's how you know the stories
and he was like hold these yeah
yeah exactly i held this long glove oh
my god
your life is awesome yeah
says prince i got this thing with kelly
clarkson
do you remember the first time we met
we were on saturday night live i was the
host and she was the musical guest yeah
and that's when i knew i had arrived
kelly's going to be the musical guest
[Laughter]
it was great i was freaking out it's
just i'm such a fan he was freaking out
i was too i was freaking out and i think
in that night too i was so like just
caught off guard it's so late you don't
realize like it's so late when you're
performing live obviously and like i i
remember i changed the lyrics to break
and it was like all i wanted was horses
i just i just like
two things all i wanted was horses and i
was like what oh well kelly you realize
that doing live television is like being
shot out of a cannon
it's like literally you're in front of
20 million people performing yeah and if
you're not michael jackson that's like
oh
yes that's why i talked about horses
okay so i want to know because you've
been on snl for and i want to know like
one of your favorite characters that
you've ever gotten to play
wow uh i mean all of any time i was on
camera at snl the 15 year old me was
extremely excited about it but i mean
like
uh gosh they all change it is a certain
energy like when you're like i've been
there like just performing and stuff
have you you've hosted uh no i don't
know after all you would be it's such a
commitment
i i was actually in new york when blake
shelton hosted because i was there for
that he was great i know but it's a
commitment you all work all week people
don't get it it's not just saturday
night it's like it's a lot of work yeah
yeah i feel like you were someone that
it would excel at it though because oh
really larry i said you like don't i
feel like you would let them have fun
and have a good time oh i would
definitely lean in and have a good time
i feel like you would be a great host
okay okay okay
i love that thank you thank thank you
was great do you remember like your very
first time that you were on snl because
you said your 15 year old was freaking
out so like what was like your first do
you remember
yeah i i totally remember it was like
space camp uh it was it was nuts i mean
like the first episode was the only one
i enjoyed because i was like i'm here i
can't believe it and then there was a
job after that yeah
uh yeah no i definitely like in between
two scenes in my first episode like ran
full speed across the studio and changed
really fast because we're on live tv and
then i had like a minute and a half
and i was just standing there going like
man yeah
i guess i guess i'm very excited to be
here
oh my god you got your pocket protector
on yeah it's very my old snl book i love
it so wait do you remember your first
time performing in front of a crowd were
you nervous or did you feel at home i
don't think i was nervous and maybe
that's why i'm here now i think i played
like santa claus when i was a kid in
school yeah like in like third grade and
remember being like yeah
the kid never gets played santa claus
that's awesome
yeah i wasn't even chubby then like no i
just mean like most kids have to be we
have to be like elves or something you
got to be like the big man i got to be
santa yeah i was like the only one who
said yes and i had a beard when i was
four
no no
i love that yeah and and then every year
for nine years at snl it was like it's
december you got to put on a santa claus
costume five times a week for the next
month oh my god that's awesome though i
love that wait i love that your first
time wasn't scary though a lot of times
when performers would say they were
terrified and i was like that's why i
feel like i'm here like i i enjoyed it
like my first time i was ever on stage
it was like it kind of felt like home
away from home yeah i remember like
the i was like the big finish at the end
was putting on this santa claus jacket
and it was inside out and like they did
it like they handed it to me wrong oh
and i remember like
making some joke about it and then like
putting it on and like it got a big
laugh then a star was born
a podcast and it's celebrity settings
right so so what is your coolest
celebrity setting or weirdest i'll take
any oh
wow i have a podcast called celebrity
sighting with jonathan biting i play a
character a hundred year old man that's
him uh i play a 100 year old man named
jonathan biden who hides in bushes and
takes pictures of celebrities um
uh my weirdest celebrity encounter gosh
i i wish i had a better one like just
regularly on the street i did i ran into
anthony daniels the guy who played c-3po
on the street and i recognized him and i
think he was shocked that i recognized
him out of costume i think but he was
walking like c-3po um and uh
he was uh and uh but i think maybe
they'll know who i am
i think by far the weirdest one was
definitely at snl
uh i was walking down the hallway in a
moose costume with a moose head as you
do as you do and uh sarah palin walked
by me i've never never met her before
yeah never said a word to her her first
words to me as she walked by she never
looked at me she just went
moose
oh my god
that's actually
fantastic
[Laughter]
super weird she's ready to go hunting
she had it she had it ready i feel like
not her first moose that she's
encountered
not in alaska now
definitely inside dirty rocks
so what did you love about the city
you've been here for years what was yeah
you first moved here what was like your
favorite thing to do well i mean i think
that like a lot of new yorkers you just
can't believe like how close everything
is like every cuisine you'd ever want to
try
is just a block away and it's also the
great thing about new york is that
people behave exactly the way you always
hoped new yorkers would
i remember like early on like one of my
first days running uh to snl and i had
uh a script in uh like a manila envelope
and uh unstapled script and it just blew
away
and people were walking not a single
person stopped to help me but a lot of
them pointed where the paper was going
it was people on their phone and they
just go there it's in the street
new york is full of supervisors yeah
just a lot of like people and also
people always say like do you get
stopped
as a celebrity do you get stopped in new
york much and i always say you don't
because everyone who lives in new york
thinks they're a celebrity
like anything that's awesome i think
it's great yeah no one else that's
amazing that's amazing when i started i
remember like my first year on the show
being at a bar in new york and the
bartender said has anyone told you you
look like that guy on snl and i said i
was so excited because i hadn't been
recognized before and i said i am that
guy on snl and he said shut up
that totally happens to me people think
you look like kelly clark 20 years in no
and i'll be like oh i am and they're
like no you're not and i'm like
oh no i'm not and then they're like are
you yes i am no you're not we have this
argument back and forth and then i just
give up and i'm like no you know what
you should do is you should ask for
their name and whatever they say go no
you're not
but but wait do you do you do um did you
grow up like doing impressions no i
didn't do impressions at all and i was
terrible doing impressions on snl and
then i just you know you weren't no i
was you're a liar uh no i don't we like
to pretend we like to talk about how bad
i am at the impressions on the show
that's uh but you know but that's
probably that's that thing of like
aren't i terrible and just like
desperate for praise
clap for me yeah yeah who have you have
you done impressions all right here's
the thing it's very polarizing at the
show a lot of people on the staff think
i'd do a terrible vince vaughn i'm going
to do my vin swan for you ready
i love it don't build it up
just to be like ready it's a it's a
three word impression and it's the same
word three times okay ready
buddy buddy buddy
so
you know how much i love you yeah this
is not good
see buddy buddy buddy no that's like
because vince vaughn is often trying to
convince someone who is a friend of his
to a bad idea and he often like prefers
it was like body body buddy
it's already doing work
so is it true that before you got snl
that you were actually trying to make a
living doing commercials no i would i
wasn't trying to like make it i would go
to auditions yeah for commercials yeah
but that's making a living it's paying
the bills when you saw what they paid
you not really yeah
i did i did a commercial
uh for a furniture store okay uh where i
this is my line i remember i don't
remember the name let's say it was
chicago couches okay it was something
along the lines of at chicago couches
they put the customer first that's me
i'm the customer pretty good and i will
tell you i did not get paid enough to
buy a couch i did not oh my god yeah it
wasn't a lot people just think once
you're on tv you make yeah they think
that's the thing they see you on tv once
they think you've got money for
everybody yeah they're like i don't even
have couch money i remember even after
idol people thought oh gosh she's like
loaded no you're not oh yeah they said
oh it's a million dollar and it's like a
contract you never see it you never it's
like no they show you a million dollars
yeah yeah okay wait well we need to talk
about snl a little bit i've asked
because this is the funniest thing
that's happened on my show okay i've
asked jimmy seth and maya about this
because it was apparently an epic night
but what do you remember from the snl
40th anniversary party and does it
involve prince no
oh what's your print story oh baby let
me tell you and this is a true story
okay i love prince oh my god all my life
child prince brought me into the life
prince brought me into the world i knew
prince when he was naked on the horse
you know what i'm saying
do you notice that's the real prince
right there the prince y'all see that's
that's the prince after the horse you
know what i'm saying
so i was like when he came to us and i
was like oh my god i got to meet prince
so we went to the rehearsal and i'm just
sitting there going oh my god prince is
in front of me this is incredible so i'm
standing in the back and at that that
week chris rock was the host so i'm
standing in the back i'm standing in the
back full
uh you know uh some hawk and everything
all you can see is my teeth in the dark
cause i'm just like
[Laughter]
red
[Laughter]
so he comes off the stage and starts
heading towards me
and it's like he's coming towards me and
i'm like
princess headed towards me
princess hannah taught me princess had
to talk to me
so he cut he gets right he gets like
about right here and you could see in
his face that he made a mistake oh no
so he's still but he's very sweet so he
stepped calm he kept coming and he he
grabs my hand and i said you thought i
was chris rock didn't you wait
[Applause]
[Laughter]
he went
yes i did oh my god yes i did he owned
it oh my god you don't look at me
i do in the dark oh my god oh my god i
love you so much
[Laughter]
[Music]
but the 40th was off the chain for me
because it was like one of the first
like big seasons i was at snl so i i had
met famous people but the 40th was
famous people like i met leonardo
dicaprio i meant uh
i met all kinds of but this is the best
story for me for the 40th i don't know
if people remember this but we were
standing in the back just partying man
i'm like i'm partying and i look to the
back everybody's getting up there you
know dan aykroyd jimmy fallon up there
singing you know come on
you know just going off you know it was
awesome right so i look back
look in the back michael bolton is
standing in the back and he's just
looking like
man i want to get up there man
did he get up man i wish somebody would
ask me to get up that man
he was just looking around like huh
they know that michael bolton's in the
back i don't think know michael brown's
back so i went over saying i was like
michael bolton i was like do you want to
sing the night and he was like nah nah
you know you try to play that hum i was
like no i'm not complaining you gonna
sing he let me pull him to the front put
him to the front right put him to the
front and i i waved jim i was like jimmy
jimmy michael barton he was like oh
michael bolton let me tell you something
michael baldwin got up there and
shut
it
down i win on me
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
afterwards his i think his publicist
came up to me she was like you made his
died i was like he made eye night like
my gosh i love his voice so badly he did
i'm talking about everybody's knees just
went oh my god
yeah that voice whoa then correct it's a
little raspy oh i'm into it so what were
you were you i always think this
everybody on this note were you like
voted class clown in high school did
everybody know where you were headed
it was so the thing was the category was
class clown but the the title of the
category was most likely to be on snl
which like
was just but it was just like a floored
way of saying oh he's like a ham and
he's
he's whatever that's not most likely to
be on snl but like it but in a way like
but back then it like didn't mean
anything to me i was like oh okay cool
what because the prettiest person was
like most likely to be on the cover of
vogue it was like that kind of thing
that's totally what i got yeah yeah yeah
they were like she's gonna be a model um
that's did you ever get anything did
y'all do that where you grew up when you
get most likely
uh no you didn't do most likely
no i think uh they said that my school
that i was good at lots of things but
not that good anything
a jack-of-all-trades no they said in a
nice way
but i really like to be a pop star they
said well keep dreaming oh my god and
look a lot of people tell me that too
chris look at us now look at us now
lester was just here y'all both were at
30 rocks so what was like your most
memorable moment at snl because i've
been there a few times and it's crazy
how fast-paced it is yes and we would
actually run into the anchors in the
elevator as they were starting their
morning and we were ending our day
because like snl obviously so we're
there so late but yeah
truly like every waking moment on that
show is memorable and surreal but
especially when you first get there
because
you don't really know what yeah like
you're going from being this completely
unknown improviser to suddenly you're in
the studio and like lady gaga's eating
chicken fingers on the floor and you're
like
this is normal wow this is normal yeah
even if you don't like see them they're
physically all the the pictures
everything up there it's just such a a
museum of like what's
all the amazing things that have
happened over the years yeah like week
one you're just kind of thrown into it
yeah it's so fun okay well last time i
saw you kristen bell was here with us
and i love that you had no idea that she
was living in your guest house i did not
know that i knew that uh uh how do you
not know did you never go there i wasn't
trying to never go
i lived in her back house yeah
so we no she uh well there were times i
was doing uh snl at the time and i was
in new york so i owned a home in l.a and
one of my friends we had a mutual friend
and she would stay uh in my guest room
and she and that friend would guess they
were great friends so she would come
over there but i don't know if she was
really staying there or she was i think
she was chris i think she was just
hanging out i think i think she was
living in your guest
i seriously didn't ever know that or
know that i still think that's probably
well you might want to check your guest
house tonight when you get home i might
someone's flipping it just some remnants
yeah i have to ask you what's your
what's your favorite snl character that
you've like ever played
oh this is my favorite one that i played
yeah
well
i like doing the ones with other people
because i do like uh performing with
other people the most yeah team i think
that's yeah
team playing was always fun like uh
there's a character name uh there was a
a
character called azrael abyss that was
got a goth character with molly shannon
we're called it was called goth talk
and i would go i'm asrael abyss i'm the
prince of sorrow
i remember that anyone remember that
audience
top
[Music]
you